More than 90 percent of the population lives below the federal poverty line.
The tuberculosis rate on Pine Ridge
is approximately eight times higher than the US national average.
The infant mortality rate is the highest on this continent,
and is about three times higher than the US national average.
Cervical cancer is five times higher
than the US national average.
The school dropout rate is up to 70 percent.
Teacher turnover is eight times higher than the US national average.
Frequently, grandparents are raising their grandchildren
because parents, due to alcoholism,
domestic violence and general apathy,
cannot raise them.
Fifty percent of the population over the age of 40
suffers from diabetes.
The life expectancy for men is between 46 and 48 years old --
roughly the same as in Afghanistan and Somalia.
The last chapter in any successful genocide
is the one in which the oppressor
can remove their hands and say,
"My god -- what are these people doing to themselves?
They're killing each other.
They're killing themselves
while we watch them die."
This is how we came to own these United States.
This is the legacy
of Manifest Destiny.
Prisoners are still born into prisoner of war camps,
long after the guards are gone.
These are the bones left after the best meat has been taken.
A long time ago,
a series of events was set in motion
by a people who look like me, by wasichu,
eager to take the land and the water and the gold in the hills.
Those events led to a domino effect that has yet to end.
As removed as we, the dominant society, may feel
from a massacre in 1890,
or a series of broken treaties 150 years ago,
I still have to ask you the question:
How should you feel about the statistics of today?
What is the connection between these images of suffering
and the history that I just read to you?
And how much of this history do you need to own, even?
Is any of this your responsibility today?
I have been told that there must be something we can do.
There must be some call to action.
Because for so long, I've been standing on the sidelines,
content to be a witness,
just taking photographs.
Because the solutions seem so far in the past,
I needed nothing short of a time machine to access them.
The suffering of indigenous peoples is not a simple issue to fix.
It's not something everyone can get behind
the way they get behind helping Haiti,
or ending AIDS, or fighting a famine.
The "fix," as it's called,
may be much more difficult for the dominant society
than, say, a $50 check
or a church trip to paint some graffiti-covered houses,
or a suburban family
donating a box of clothes they don't even want anymore.
So where does that leave us?
Shrugging our shoulders in the dark?
The United States continues on a daily basis to violate the terms
of the 1851 and 1868 Fort Laramie Treaties with the Lakota.
The call to action I offer today --
my TED wish -- is this:
Honor the treaties.
Give back the Black Hills.
It's not your business what they do with them.
(Applause)